yeah until 9 36 eastern here we go all
right
wow that's a massive rating for such a
small guy let's see what we got going on
fpmark oh come on chigorin is a very
underestimated opening
all right what about always been my
dream to play trigordon against sam
shanklin i don't remember let's go
bishop
four i think this is what i gave in the
course very quiet okay maybe here one
month like this
this is supposed to be okay for white i
think i remember i have had this against
david prus
uh who is the queen b3
okay you're having none of it yeah
all right so unbalance the positions my
strategy
you're just begging me to cut so long
and made to i'm not much of an attacker
but
i think i have to try right ah not much
of an attacker says the us champion
that's a good move lazy attaching thank
you my goal is to be annoying here yeah
that's uh
well you're doing a good job so far
all right so i guess i'll take it
you want to take on a2 um
my d5 might have something to say about
that
this actually at first i thought this
was just a one mover but it's actually
more annoying than it looks
oh you mean rogue g1 yeah i mean what do
you want to play g6
no i don't you know what i'm going to do
i'm going to beef up that king's side
that's a good move isn't it um
and the only question everybody wants to
hear the story by the way so
whenever convenient sam you have you you
have an inimitable way of sharing it
the one
but whenever i don't want to distract
you from like a complicated position
that's not a play
okay we'll take it uh and games yep
boring but i actually think i'm better
here so i agree with myself i agree
i have several things to defend against
okay let's defend against this all right
so end with the rook
oh i forgot how annoying you are sam
bishop h6 do i miss something i you
might have i don't know that was my idea
all right yes but okay
um okay so i take this and then
i go take your knight with an extra
point very technical
okay but how winning is this it's it's
not that easy i'm better but
it will take some work to win this and
you're a tricky fella
that is true okay let's get this i think
i should
i think this should be technically i'm
flirting with but
be my guest right yeah yeah yeah
no let's go five sure okay
um i think some idiot wrote that pawns
don't move backwards you want to play h5
um it actually doesn't seem like a
terrible idea
okay it does all right um
just because you proposed it otherwise i
would have played it
okay now they come back
okay this is not as easy as i would like
this f5 f5 move i'm beginning to kind of
regret
yeah no i think i think i'm gonna get
this one okay
the last defensive ideas here okay let's
go here for now
yeah who said panzo move backwards that
definitely was an idiot
so h4 okay eight
okay so i guess i should keep this
locked up to the extent that i can
it's probably pretty dumb but that's
okay let's lock everything up
okay so the opponent game is losing i
would think so
i mean i could be wrong no you ain't
wrong
but i have some ideas yes so come
up here is my idea my only idea
if i take this and come back
and then b3 and what do i miss
nothing nothing you missed that this is
the slow case a couple more moves
like that okay
check yes that's two minutes all right i
didn't get swept
that's the that's that's the first goal
well my goal is not to get swept
all right let's play some sicilians oh
that's a really manly opening you just
see if you're still in you know it's uh
who elephant was elephant was the
epitome
i have absolutely no idea what i'm doing
here i don't either actually i
the last time i played this was bellford
2005. were you playing that
no no no i was that was long before i
would got reasonably all right
yeah my mommy taught me that these
structures here are good for white if
the knights on c6 but bad if my knight
can get
to um f6 so i think the black shield my
mommy didn't teach me
these structures at all oh well but you
are one good
all right so i guess i'm supposed to put
my note on f6 right
i believe sue
all right queen c7 should we play like a
real person
i think well let's talk over okay it's
blitz let's do it
okay i like it no queen takes eight but
should be seven yeah
that was my idea
okay i'll buy it i'll buy it
so h6 is sort of forced
okay now you're trying to hurt me i see
what you're up to
so if i take and play bishop b7 i can't
believe you're gonna make me here
it's a buzz saw that is a bus
okay we'll go back i should have
blundered c3 oh my god
oh i'm really gonna take it okay um
these positions can get pretty dangerous
if you take on h6 so let's not let that
happen
yeah no forks no tricks yeah i kind of
have to do this maybe
yeah just need to get the calorie in
okay three lifting sure
what do i do now no tougher decision but
i've been told that you're very good if
your opponent has no time so i'm going
to have to
maybe you've been sold yeah i'm decent
you know i can i can i've known to
be known to flag a couple people caused
them to retire
and you got a kamsky to retire by
flagging him
well that was a long time ago but let's
just say god i wasn't too happy it
might i'm normally not allowed to
advocate flagging but that's
pretty funny all right woof king of fate
why not i gotta get off the h7 square
there's tactics there
there he is and there's okay bishop f1
sure let's go rick d8
itching to play a particular move and
you know me very well you probably know
what move this is
ah that's what you wanted i mean it's
seems like you sort of have to right
your position's just not good if you
don't all right right
exactly this is my idea sure
so queen comes to d6
queen's not a great blockader of that
pawn but i also think i should be
pretty comfortable here not the fake is
be my guest
okay that's a dangerous move
okay so i have to play king g8 or can i
use
let's start with g6 maybe let's go g6
okay soften soften it up a little bit
yeah let's go back here
okay five try to surround this pawn and
take it without pinning myself horribly
okay i'll make this little move devious
clever so i have to go to g8
i need some tactics it smells of tactics
you're like i suggest you burn yourself
all the way down to no time and to try
to find something yeah i'll take another
minute and two seconds that's right
let's just go here
just like in the night off thanks cowboy
for the sub okay
all right um let's go rookie seven
okay queen c3 sure all right
so you've tempted me enough for me to
take this one
yeah i will admit
so queen takes d5 bishop c4 am i crushed
i don't think i am i think i have this
maybe yes
oh [ __ ]
that's all i do any reason to keep
playing this game
do you miss me yet uh
seven am i done here i don't know
actually no i shouldn't have done that
yeah okay but i'm still hopelessly lost
but
as long as i don't blunt on the queen
how easy is this i don't think it's that
easy for you no it doesn't look that way
but i'm gonna lose on time because i'm
slow
yeah this is also lost once you get that
one i'm done yeah
good game good game yeah yeah all right
on one let's see
so what should we play let's play my
opening you know king's indian
joker thanks for the sub let's let's see
if you've been studying chessable or not
all right
that sounds pretty ominous i'm just
going to go with this line
knight c6 that's not good here i seem to
remember oh
windy too i'm going to castle long and
knight h5 you're going to get yourself
already much worse made it we'll see
about that who will get
it all right to play the world's worst
dragon please feel free
and the dragon is
okay let's go let's go sam you got it
absolutely vamos
uh to espanol es malissimo which is
gracias
okay spanish actually really good right
what was that my spanish yeah it's
pretty good pretty good
all right so i think i'm making this
messier than it needs to be but that's
ah
uh-huh okay
wait a minute that night i like me
some shanklin nights yeah they're tasty
okay so almost like you're cooking i can
i have a few things to do i can go nuts
i can
sacrifice stuff i can be simple and play
b3 but that feels like it's not the way
to play blitz
ah man have you tricked me here let's
see
i thought it was the world's worst
dragon
ah very clever all right let's
let's take on g6 and see how this all
right well you know what
i played the alpine last game i have to
redeem myself
so now we're gonna have some fun yes we
are
okay how crazy do i go is the question
how crazy do i go all right whatever
let's go
okay that does not feel like a good move
i agree
it's just something looks off but i
suggest you spend two minutes to the dot
refuting it
actually it's more now the more i'm
thinking about it the more i'm realizing
it's pretty good
just what i wanted you to say suck
a key love with the new emotes by the
ways guys enjoy i'll talk about that
later
this is ugly um
this is why i suck i can't play quickly
all right take the dragon bishop
no i want it no no
no you ain't having that sam you give
that to me
get myself killed here in like three
more moves
all right let's remain down a piece and
hope for the best
okay
well if you insist
this one yeah so i had some vague
ideas of sacrificing i don't even know
what exactly
i didn't think they worked here all
right oh we're having fun
has that ever stopped me from stacking a
piece
no actually yeah you're absolutely right
it doesn't work
you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna get
this guy out of there i understand
okay sure let's close that bishop unless
your king wants to join the fun
yes it does it does
okay okay i'm going to be very mad at
myself
but now the king doesn't want to join
the fun anymore sam so
i think i might evacuate
uh that's the question to which i didn't
dedicate my resources quite yet
okay back to e6
seems sensible enough
check okay gotta go here king f7 bishop
h7 there
yeah i can play bishop h7 anyway of
course
absolutely spending too much time
all right now you're gonna get away with
this that's frustrating
i don't know i'm still pretty scared
but yeah it looks like salvation is
close
at hand i don't know i thought you
should have run with the king sooner now
i could at least
make some trouble for him definitely
okay here challenge the defending piece
so if we give you ah i see what you want
okay we're just gonna go back sure
okay challenge it again
how annoying can you get you're fine
here come on
yeah i know all right so here
oh oh my god
man i say why you sacrifice stuff
unsoundly it's so much fun
it is very fun opponent feels all the
pressure but
i think i might yeah but here i think
you're surviving all right make a fast
pawn
oh almost played 96.
what was wrong with it was the best move
ah shoot now that's
lost all right you got this one good
game time to bring out the story
probably all right
yeah so one time i was playing daniel in
the last round of some tournaments and
um
we both we were tied for first and he
needed well i was a bit stronger than
him he was black he clearly
should have been happy with the draw but
um
uh but he really misplayed the beginning
and at some point he was very young and
his ears were the only orifice in his
face not oozing liquid
um but uh he pulled himself together he
he got a tissue and then he proceeded to
defend beautifully and
actually should have saved the game at
the end but then blundered it away
just when it was and then my ears were
once again the
only orifice that yeah but you had class
i mean clearly you were very upset
but you shook my hand like a champion
and uh
thank you that's so you know someone's
gonna be good someday you know everybody
can lose horribly but
uh if you like and it has to hurt but
if it hurts you so much that it
completely crushes you you're never
going to really get good
right delicate balance to motivate
you to come back that's better
ooh f4 i don't know these positions too
well f4 looks wrong but
what exactly okay i mean if you're going
to do it it's sort of strange to have
the rook on f1
and so to put the rook on you one first
right through
i was flirting with some ideas kind of
dangerous for black
yeah this is the feel like smells of
something
okay let's have some fun how exactly are
we
okay whatever let's just go here g5
you're gonna shut me down aren't you
that was the plan but this looks scarier
than i was hoping it would be
um okay so i gotta bring the knight back
to f6 i guess
centralize so
i don't love my position all of a sudden
i even know what i did wrong
um actually
okay
it's gonna be five and try it again some
space i was sort of worried about e5 but
i have an idea it's a very silly
interview
i think that's reverse psychology you
you actually don't want me to play
five i mean it's interesting i'm not
sure it's that great for me i don't like
it
i'm gonna go a3
sure okay so we have to open some
counter play lines
okay now what if i
i know what you're going to be thinking
i'm going to grab this
okay that's actually not as dumb as i
was hoping it would be
um so knight back to d7 i guess is
probably the best way to try to punish
you but i don't think it'll work that
well
no you're too good daniel i remember
when i used to be able to beat you
oh man do you remember our first game in
carol capps memorial
yeah it went it made its way into my
book
yeah that's that was something else all
right this is a thousand
four i think okay now let's get here
yeah
okay so i gotta challenge this guy
someday
all right so take this and now i think i
might be more or less surviving
all right back we go
okay this is my chance to
do nothing yeah
it's not pretty but i might
all live all right right right
i need to find a way i'm gonna go here
for now
see what you do um let's get the queen
back to the defense and out of danger
seems like a good start
and then my plan was rex c3 and to give
my queen
but lady interesting
um do i have to
not really but we're having fun let's do
wait a second there's some cool stuff
going on here
all right let's go here either i just
blonder again
i think you're fine actually but there's
many moves here that are interesting
i missed e5 completely though i'm just
lucky that it doesn't win on the spot
okay i gotta move
take like 95 or something
back i have to be fine here
well now i'm going to be the one getting
flat
that's a good move though
that's a really good move here
that's also a good move yeah
it's almost like you're the us champion
i was once upon a time
okay
a different life
okay
well i'm gonna flag
0.2 okay oh my god why did i move my
rook away from the first
i don't know all right let's see if you
can kings that do that same king's
indian again without
dying a horrible death i'm gonna do it
again
all right i'm doing it again until you
prove it
until i prove it he says
okay um is bishop e6 part of the planet
by castle short i don't believe it
actually it's not
i didn't expect to castle shirt i don't
know maybe that is
maybe that is the refutation i mean i'm
clearly better here but it's not that
much and it's going to be hard to put
you away
uh but maybe i mean i didn't know maybe
i can just made you if i cast along and
play a little bit less
like a dance but all right
uh clean trade
it's very solid for luck it is very hard
but i'm still gonna let you do it
because i don't want you to trick me and
without queens you have a harder time
okay
what should we do if f5 is interesting
probably bad
yeah five is definitely better let's go
f6 yeah that seems
prudent all right so start solidify
there let's get right
yeah c1 is very nasty yeah but this is
the kind of thing that's just so hard in
blitz you're
well it's always a little better but to
actually put the game away it takes
right
yeah you gotta always understand when to
risk
but knight c5 felt a bit rushed and now
i'm patting myself on the back for my
idea to play g3 in advance
all right let's change the structure
sure
okay all right so how bad is this for me
you're a bit worse i don't think you're
dead
okay let's change the structure he said
let me put it this way if you play this
against dingler and you will lose every
side
and if you played against somebody who's
not dingler and you might have some
chances to survive
just thinking about that gives me the
chills yeah
i'm actually really regretting ef5 did i
have to do that
maybe it's not the worst duck house
challenge the newly opened file now that
the work is evacuated
get the king up that's a good idea a
little copy
okay why ding oh well
this man's technique is something else
it's not just his technique i mean
there's lots of guys with good technique
but he's specifically good at like d4
position technique
uh-huh um but yeah my whole plan now is
that i get these i go
here all right keep changing the
structure
yeah maybe i shouldn't have allowed that
but
i still think i'm probably a bit better
here so it takes
three guesses what your next move is um
interesting forcing me to make a
decision
okay you know what i'm gonna do not
really right
okay i can't resist the temptation d5
okay so if i play roxy one you have king
e6 as your big idea
maybe um
i would have provoked you maybe i'll
just come right back
i had an idea here i thought of this
move
okay and if b5 there's some tricks or
that's probably not that bad for you but
i have to give it a try
some cool stuff here like this
oh have i blondered a weird a very weird
professional
that's a perpetual yeah all right let's
do it that's pretty cool
it's a very weird perpetual but
okay so what's the score now we're even
even at two and a half two and a half
okay let's go beef it let's change the
scenery a little bit
okay i did my chest little repertoire
and studied two games where you played
this ridiculous g4 move you want to try
it again
you know what i am all right let's do it
okay let's do it yeah
no knight f3 i think is the idea yes
and this is what i did yeah that was
what you did the second time
and i'm just gonna go here i have i have
grown believe it or not i actually
checked this in preparation for today
and now i can't even remember what i
wanted
but uh that's exactly what i mean i
think it's cringy for
and then that's an annoying move
i'm pretty sure i checked this and i
think i'm gonna go
what should i do here let's go here
that's the best move and then there's
this very funky move rook
h6 which prepares for g6 and your worst
there you go daniel blitzing out moves
with white until you're worse than girl
all right so hang on g6 and i just don't
know it's one thing to say i'm worse but
let's see how you react to this one
okay so i guess i have to go c6
it's normal enough take back
ricky one ah that's clever all right so
knight e7 and then
but 97 knight b5 knight a6 then you have
a check that's a problem
96. so i guess i have to go king d7
okay sam you got to make something
happen here you are dead in like three
moves if i completely
no i i am going to make something to
happen you have faith in me
i do you're good at that but okay let's
start with this move
okay so three guesses what that has in
mind
i guess i can start with 97
right but not bishop yeah i don't know
okay now i can't i cannot allow bishop
g7 right
so all right
let's go knight c6 and now we're gonna
go humans
my thought was i could play g5 but now
i'm wondering if you can go knight h5
rascal it's almost like you do tactics
occasionally
i know h5 is a good move there
but i might not have that much of a
choice
yeah somehow pressure it's not that easy
here a little annoying
um so how bad is it if i let you take my
guy
it's probably not that bad but let's
just go knight f5
nah and then you take and take h5 but
that's okay for me so let's do that
um i want to take and take h5 though
i mean you probably should and i've
misplayed it and i think you're fine
there
yeah but you're also definitely not
better
um okay i thought i was oh but you want
i have some ideas here okay
so i guess i have to go reggie six
okay let's go back here okay
yeah i thought this breakfast in some
world i thought this was good
for me to provoke but now i really
really i'm
but actually you know i'm good at
creating tricks here i don't think
you're that much worse or anything
no no hang on d3 seems pretty good right
yeah let's do it are you sure oh you
have rookie options
oh i shot myself in the foot i'm sure
you would you saw it though anyway
i was about to take okay wow i was
thinking i shot myself in the foot for
absolutely no reason i could have just
played bishop c5 and been slightly
better but
it's not entirely over actually yeah
okay i'm worse but not crushed here
right okay i'm gonna take
really you want to give me f2 as well
doesn't that give you too many weak
bonds
it gives me quite a few i agree i'll
start here i'll be okay actually
yeah i didn't really evaluate this i
just assumed trading rooks is good for
me
came at the cost of a pretty important
fun that is true
okay i'm gonna have to play passive
passive defense you should still be
better here but
phineas thank you jesus
oh you just missed rook f1 oh my god
but why did i decide to play chess for a
living
we all ask ourselves the same question
all the time
jack that's a nasty little blockade
yeah okay let's provoke are you even
better here
i don't know i don't think so but i'm
gonna try to trick you
you're gonna flag me is what you're
gonna do well
not if it went the way the last game
went
okay let's go up
okay let's go around
oh yeah yeah there's tricking who
you're tricking me no i don't know
but you're still fine ah [ __ ]
now you tricks me again i don't know
now you tricked me
don't have enough time to do this
i think this is winning now
okay sorry it's all good oh good i knew
what i was signing up for
i'm not gonna take it personal all right
so we're doing this again we're doing
this okay but i'll
deviate a little bit as you wish
i don't really know anything else okay
let's go c6 yeah good rule of thumb
whenever they play c6 you mute it with
d5 yeah that is true
this one i think is supposed to be very
bad for you g4
interesting all right i'll test it
right and i think the whole premise is
that here
because you have played c5 you don't get
uh
the c5 square for your knights and the
pawn on e6 d6 is much weaker than it
might otherwise be
maybe knight f5 i should have knight f5
sounds more natural and here i think i
can sort of attack you on all parts of
the board at the same time
so queen h4 seems like a good move
let's attack the queen okay i'm gonna
play with fire here a little bit yeah i
suppose
probably sort of what you have to do
here right i mean create some chances
okay hang on rook g1 and what's the big
idea i don't see
it knight g4 and i have rook g2 and then
i'm threatening knight g1
and i think you're out of steam um
out of steam i could be wrong
but no i i'm not seeing much steam
to be found there this is the problem
the pawn is on c5 you need to be able to
play knight c5 knight e4 and come here
right without it it's very difficult to
create chances
that's why i think g4 makes sense once
you have played c5
uh-huh okay let's go here really playing
with fire
heaven g5
sort of begging to be played it is go
ahead
but let me think if rook g3 ef3 is your
big idea
exactly um so i gotta go knight g5
i'm gonna make the move first and ask
questions later now
now what do i do rook g3 maybe
seems pretty good let's do it go
side step yep
so it's harder to put away than i was
thinking it would be
all right sequential one makes sense
things you think if you take that rook
you might just end up worse but
yeah just slightly but i i like the
architectural arrangement of the bishops
on e5 and f5
all right um okay let's just keep
playing
okay i need to get that knight involved
yeah
as soon as i moved i realized that was a
problem all right
bring work to g1 yes yes yes
i need to do something
what ah this one maybe
i see your point now very tricky
very tricky bishop gcd yep
that's rather a shame damn you're too
good daniel help playing me every game
let's complicate the game i was afraid
you'd do that you put a little
rascal you have a choice you're as
annoying as i remember
that's me that's good i have to take
with
a rook right i think so
yeah now i'm gonna occupy this then i
thought i can come back
okay i think it might be time okay
drop it back
i don't think i'm that much worse here i
actually think white is lost
really i feel like your position is kind
of falling apart here with all these
ideas bishop g4 bishop b4 etc
it might be right so let's see
yeah i see what you're trying to do i'm
just going to throw
this in the mix and hope for the best
okay
hmm then i go here
okay i see what you want i'm just gonna
lose on time though
but now i have idea
let's go here clever
that's an annoying move and i have no
time to okay so i have to go knight f6
man this feels very flimsy but i don't
see a way through but as always i'm
gonna lose on time i'm actually
calculating
some lines
okay we're gonna centralize sure
all right let's have some fun
oh my god that's not good but here
oh did you trick me oh that's painful
but i mean how bad is this what is this
oh no
no i'm just such a game wait a minute
tim
you bet you better show some technique
okay
as you wish i'm kidding yeah
all right again
that was painful put some more societies
okay let's go here okay
that's a tricky move actually doesn't
look totally stupid
all right so if i play five do you have
a big idea
no just develop if you cannot bring a
bishop to c4 i don't think you're going
to mute me
telling me black sports here no it's
probably fighting for equality which is
what i normally do
with white okay
sure but i'm not so sure a king is as
safe as you think it is
mine i might be right um
all right we're blind that's what's so
fun sure
what's your big idea as you say that's
simple
i don't know i just sort of hoped that
this worked but i don't think it does
well right when i was equalizing the
match too i just
wandered d4 and now i can resign in one
move that's pretty bad
ah all right i'm still sour over the
last game though
yeah you gotta try to try some tricks
you know okay let's find fine i'll let
you
experiment so
i said take this
yeah yeah yeah okay now we gotta find
something here put this it shouldn't be
too hard thank you thank you away
actually isn't that easy here i don't
like it the way you said that
okay i haven't just busted but like
i think i know what i'm doing though so
let me see
or do i
okay i can actually just play calmly
or no okay let's go here
i was hoping you wouldn't find that all
right
um it's probably the end
so i guess i have to play fishing six
but this is not gonna be
good
yeah i mean bishop c4 was probably also
winning but
i feel like this just keeps the people
what if can i take c3 though
i'm not sure oh yeah
so this seems very bad
all right take and b5 and hope for the
best
but no question i'm very much lost here
i need to somehow i need to drive that
rook out
i'm going to do it at the cost of the
pawn
drive it up sure oh crap
damn it you saw my trick i did queen v6
rascal okay i don't even know if i'm
worse anymore
too many blunders in these technical
positions
are you good at talking and playing at
the same time i really suck
i'm not great but um
i've adapted sort of all right
oh if you lose this game just to clean
piece up i'm gonna laugh at you
well i better not lose it then i'll
laugh at myself almost just took that
rook
oh my god why don't you take it it's a
free rock yeah
okay so
let's see what do i start with i think
you're gonna regret what you just said
thank you alexander for the sub okay c3
jesus christ that's pretty damn oh man
oh you're right i am going to regret
what i just said
oh my gosh back to the chigornia
okay i didn't prepare this especially
for the match or anything
i i've been dabbling in the true horn
all right
so let's go to d2 this time i wasn't
totally thrilled without the last one
check out
i think him against venuely like this
so i think i have to not take that right
away
okay you're not playing me all the time
man
all right
i've played every game so let's
challenge this bishop
let it find a square
okay
okay you know what i'm gonna play it
like this
really yeah okay i thought the knight on
d4 is is really good here
yeah you're probably fine but i thought
you could have
done more yeah
um
yeah now we're gonna cement maybe you
should play queen h5 and i'll uh not
defend
good advice okay let's start with
keeping everything nice and solid
okay good
okay let's go it's an annoying
russian kind of move no that's me
wait did you want me to play queen h5 g6
quincy five ninety two and you're
getting very tricky one i'd be three
actually i thought but
okay so let's start with rookie one all
right it's no more
coins actually kind of bad yeah there's
no real
okay this one yeah as soon as i said it
i found an acceptable square but
okay seven is hanging is this an
acceptable score for me yeah sure
let's get off of any night tricks let's
get on some tricks
okay okay let's complete the fiance
okay
okay such a good night i'm actually
going to just
greedily take the pawn if anybody will
blame me
by all means that feels like a very bad
decision but i don't see how to punish
you for it
um
i guess let's start with this one okay
sure
okay yeah so you want
b file play what do you have here
specifically
nothing that amazing but
so this one game i thought should be
okay for me but it's
yeah you got the knight as a blockader
very instructive
so
now i think i'm starting to
yeah i may have misplayed this but how
bad can't be
pretty bad
yeah i don't like my position anymore
something went wrong
um okay gotta keep the guys up
here yeah but this i thought was gonna
save it
even rookie three doesn't help yeah that
was
that's the point but wait a second
there are some complications wait first
of all if i take and take on f4 that's
not so easy to draw is it
all right it should be a draw but it no
it will not be easy all right
so start with king d2
let this work make a decision and i
shall
okay so now we go okay
well we should abide by the principles
yeah but this i'm pretty sure it's just
a draw
so i can go here and then here
no i don't think you're gonna ever make
a way through
really oh yeah yeah that's interesting
but i'll try okay please feel free
oh i don't think i'll try
draw maestro sure
yeah that was nice very nice okay let's
go let's go with the d4s
all right
should be seven here oh this line
let's go let's have some fun soon very
comfortable for black if i recall
but it's fun so thanks now i just have
to remember how i'm supposed to play it
i know it's a rookie 8 move somewhere
um how about
why can't i remember a darn thing this
is so sad we're getting old
yeah um remember do you remember when we
were young
those were the days uh so i think that
why can't i not remember this at all
this is really sad i should spend two
minutes and 20 seconds trying to
remember maybe open the chest a little
repertoire
oh boy i think i get forfeited for that
crap
all right i think that's no this is
right yeah okay it's 2894 for king d
that's right this is not a gun here and
then there's that after
okay i'm i'm in lego queen e7 this is
the point attack this knight gainer
tempo you defended
seven rookie eight i'm in time for
rookie yeah there's one thing i don't
get
you're gonna have to show me yeah what
if i go here
this one um i think i'm supposed to just
keep running with the king
yeah i think it's rey reyes beating me
in this okay i'll take it
so now we get some ridiculous position
very quickly but jesus
oh this is fun though yeah we're going
to play a real game here
okay i need to throw some wood onto the
fire here
sure so i guess
i think my king's supposed to be pretty
good on a6
knight c7 mate not quite
damn you saw it you're really good sam
ah so are you i learned from the best
what do i
king on yes i think the king is supposed
to be pretty good here
i have one idea
all right so i guess uh your idea is i'm
going to play
c3 you're going to take twice and i'm
going to get knight c7
that doesn't sound like fun
but it seems like another idea
but i will not tell you what it is
yeah damn this position's harder than i
thought it would be
c3 bishop f1 is a problem that's right
it's small
okay um i'm spending too much time
oh shoot something went wrong here i
don't know where it was
but all right let's go bishop c6
i'll move myself for a second from sam's
call thank you akilah
and i'll give you a huge shout out later
let me see
and that is a prudent move no but um
i think i should have played a6 instead
of um
instead of b4 all right
this position sucks but i'm gonna get
what is this
i feel like i could just stare at this
position for like a year
oh yeah this is this is this is what
real chess is supposed to be not
three minute all games
so many tempting options you know okay
i'm going to play this vanilla
all right so i have to come back or no i
have to get bishop b5 right
okay
okay what's up here
all right i need to get rid of this
night
oh what if we go here
um say cb4 and you have queen b1
and then a6
a lot of ideas there that is nice but
i'm not convinced
so i'm gonna test you wait i think it's
mate
how how hell i mean i had to try right
check to his majesty not good
oh [ __ ] i got no time to all right
complicate
check and here
hmm jesus don't you wish we had more
time here this would be i know
this would be a lot of fun
x i gotta be winning here though thanks
you do
yeah no we were making sure i think i'm
winning
really okay oh now you are
all right let's switch things up and
play e4 indeed indeed
all right i didn't play chess to play
like a one let's play some knight
i really don't i haven't updated this in
the years uh the
set of ramen line i think this is what i
yeah but i'm not convinced by this like
i also
made before and now if i recall knight
c5 is supposed to be pretty good i had a
game like this
many many years back oh yeah all right
rick see it's
okay are you threatening anything i
think so
you know no
so if i go g5
okay neither back just listen
and then quench four uh you pile up on
the pawn like this yeah
i look i only need one guy
that is a true statement mr shankland
all right so i gotta take this now i'll
take this guy
you don't care about rook d6 no let's
say rook d6 rook f2
rook d7 bishop e3 king b1
okay black is winning clearly it's not
so bad for you
all right so i gotta get king b1 first
that's
do a shame to take the fun out of that
position yeah
okay after all the last game where i got
made it in one move at the end right now
i'm
gonna be okay i'm happy with boring
okay fair enough
now i can play rook f6 dude i have so
many more points than i was expecting to
have at this point
i'm pretty good at chess sam yeah but
i'm not an online player and you're like
the best in the world i mean i don't
know if that's anything to be proud of
you're the u.s champion
the author of incredible books there you
go
dude we were supposed to trash talk each
other we've been way trooper
i hope your pal is getting his money is
worth and i think i think
they are i mean the games have been fun
haven't they
yeah sam you have to say isn't this more
fun than air things
why are you watching the air things is
that how it's called
air things open that's the
the tournament that's what it's called
yeah no the chess.com
yeah orchestra whatever i would have
rather been playing there
no offense but so what he would have
rather been playing
myself i'm insulted deeply there's a
little bump that i
i missed out on the wild card but
can you idea we're just gonna ah that's
a bad move i had rook c3 was an
important idea to keep
okay so i have to keep everything
defended
i don't know it's unclear position now
all of a sudden
yeah it's supposed to be bad for you and
now it's just unclear
right um
we're just too nice yeah we're
we're getting old yeah
all right so i gotta go quick f3 i feel
like i've been totally outplayed once
more
i don't know all right so i'm not too
happy with this position
it's unclear to me
okay well i basically have to i think
actually no what do i do here
i need to this is a critical moment
okay let's just control some squares
yeah now i thought maybe g6 yeah i was
sort of happy to provoke that right
i get what you're saying
okay
okay let's go interesting complications
first take and now and get myself mated
in the background
that's the that's the plan oh boy
okay i'll take this one up for the best
knight c2 though this i was not
expecting now when it gets to d5
okay but what is the rent yeah now i
thought i can go like back to b4 maybe
so you're threatening mate which i
should probably respect i know you're
not you're not am i
i was like yeah i keep believing that um
so if i got like g5 is there's some
big scary move i think there is
whoa all right so check
i don't like the way you said that check
again
this is a big scary move
you're gonna [ __ ] draw it here i'm
waking up seven kingy six knight g7 mate
that's what i was hoping for but i'm
wondering if i can play on here
i don't think so i don't think so all
right
okay let's plan so we're like one hour
in right now right
we are exactly one hour in all right i'm
only down two games i'm proud of myself
let's go um let's go with the copic
system yeah
this thing has a name it does okay sam
uh
need i remind you the last time you
spoken this way uh
maiden one was missed and it wasn't by
me
yeah okay but i see why
you look disappointed dude i just played
like g5 and mated shibala up here in
like 10 moves when i was 2300.
well you're now 2700 so by the law of
not mating h5 coming let's go
yeah i didn't realize that you're
supposed to wait for me to castle
we're gonna have some fun though okay
i'm gonna die on my feet okay
that okay i think i'm going to have more
fun than you here but
maybe so let's see so i guess
hg4 now let's just go knight i5
now i thought i can go here i have to
have some fun at least
i mean you have to try but like i'm on
this position
but this is what i'm good at yeah okay
fair deal
all like right don't you remember the
little devious bastard that i always was
you know always was you still are right
and i'm
old bastard you're telling me you're
gonna survive this position danya i am
that's exactly what i'm telling you okay
come at me bro
some thought i said in south park not my
gym
i never could get into south park you
never liked it
too cross for you it's not that i just
don't like animated shows
oh okay it's just a weird thing i have
okay so it takes there
i thought it was just like the vulgarity
and racism and eve
bad jokes but uh i've never really seen
it i honestly like
i've it's hysterical but it's really
really a bad show if you're if you're
easily offended
um fair enough but you don't strike me
as such i'm not
but yeah it's more of the animate i just
don't like animated stuff that's a weird
thing but
just okay two itches on
if you survive this i'm gonna be really
disappointed in myself
should i borrow a phrase coined by the
great sam shankland
what's that if uh if you don't beat me
here i'm gonna laugh at you
all right so let's see
what's we gonna do now
why are you somehow alive here
live all right um
let's start with just
simple take
i've played this so badly
all right but i still kind of like my
position
still for some unknown reason
all right i can't resist any longer
okay yep
let me get it this is not as clean as i
would have liked
right not even close
but now
hmm this is interesting
had a brief inkling of hope okay but how
bad is this
yeah it's boots i get it
all right um so now i can't bring my
queen in the attack so you still have
some saving chances right
yeah and if you give me a couple moves i
consolidate okay
which is let's give you those couple of
moves
i see your appoint so let's go check
and if you have rook d8 is your big idea
so i'll trade rooks
yeah and this is the king
sure okay so i take this oh
he's got this move hmm
somehow alive here that's so distressing
wait check and then rook h2o yeah i was
hoping you wouldn't see that
yeah there's just completely no chances
here yeah yeah
all right game good game well done okay
thank you
okay let's try e4 again that was fun
yeah let's do that again
i'm going to do the same thing yeah so i
think sort of said you're supposed to
castle
instead of instead of g4 but i kind of
like this line
hmm okay i like what happened here at
first
all right so maybe i can find an
improvement and i thought of what one
might be so g5
so did i
no never mind that was just blah i just
said that because that sounded good
yeah so take screen g4 and what if i
start with h4
yeah that's what i was suspecting
okay i have an idea here though what if
i go here
sure may i seems like a good move
i don't think i should take on asics
just yet let's start by solidifying
everything
and maybe all right let's have some fun
whoa complicated
all right um
all right i didn't play around to be in
the little one what's up that's right
well that's okay who's having
i have a problem with who's having the
fun here though sam you think it's me
i feel like it might be you i think this
time you might be right but
but wait a second what if i simply take
that's what i was snacking and then i go
pee my pants
just like i did in belfort 2005. what
happened then
well there were i don't know if you know
it was the tournament was terribly
organized
to the point where nobody knew where the
bathrooms were it was like
800 degrees in the playing hall i was in
time pressure around two and you know i
did what i had to do
all right this has to fall apart somehow
but i'm not seeing it yet
all right i've told that zohan stream
before
and here if i
ship h6
i wasn't able for it now no ray
ah come on there has to be made here uh
i will sit back and drink my dr pepper
dr
pepper i my first i mean in like six
months
i felt i missed it from my high school
days
okay let's
well i have to go bishop f6 i think yes
but
uh the follow-up now is the hard part uh
so i got stripped tg-1
if you survive this i'm gonna be mad at
myself but at the same time i think
you're going to survive it so
here i don't see it soon uh you're
probably right
um
i can't even now you even are
threatening to take the bishop yeah
okay and just start throwing stuff all
right
well i have a tempo here yeah oh my
goodness
this is what i always do this was good
for me and i blew it again
this is what i've always dreamed of
but how exactly i need to
start throwing stuff at you
hmm this is not so simple actually
i feel like i have two moves though
um
all right no now you better say your
prayers
yeah uh i don't think those will save me
here
is that a gross move so it can be one
there's no
takes in c4 oh my god if you win this um
i i find that unlikely but stranger
things have happened
yeah exactly that's the second knight b3
was a very strange move
all right so you're gonna queen three
make me yes i am sir
got a problem okay
now i had an idea at the time
uh oh this isn't good
oh my goodness
unbelievable
okay
okay so what all happens now um
h6 is a draw queen g5 knight d2
king b2 knight e4 gets very goofy but
that has to be at least a draw for you
and probably mate so i'm gonna start
with h6
i'm gonna go for it sam okay
whoa all right
i think i have compensation serious
compensation oh shoots
okay messy but i'm gonna flag that's the
problem
ah shoot okay i'm not even going to play
good job
amazing amazing attack by me yes